νακαι μέσα από αυτή την αρχή έχει προχωρήσει στο νβρί έναν έναν βέρσουν του ε
αυτο του ο οποίος είναισπου δασεμηχανικός έχει δουλέψει σε πολύ διαφορετικές δουλειές και προσπαθεί πάντα
κάνει καλά τη δουλειά του για να νιώθει πεήφανος και για τον εαυτό του αλλά
και να νιώθουν περήφανει όλη γύρω του όμορθα παιδικά χρόνια πολύ όμορφα παιδικά χρόνια πάντα
όταν σκεφτο με τα παιδικά μου χρόνια στη λεμεσόν θυμάμαι πάρα πολύ ορέες αναμνήσεις ανέμελα
παιδικά χρόνια τα οποία ήταν όλο χαρά δε θυπάμε τίποτε το οποίο με στενοχωρεί και
αυτό είναι μεγάλη διαφοραίσως από την όταν εν ηλικαιωθείς και μετα όπου αρχίζεις και περνάς
διάφορες στιγμές οι οποίες μπορεία μίαι τόσο χαρούμενεςαυτά τα πίσω πάμε πισοφιλητικά χρόνια ανδρας εο
κλαους σκεφτόταν ποτε ότι θα βρεθεί στο τιμόνι του μεγαλύτερου ίσως η μικρατικόύ οργανισμού στην
κύπρο ι όχι φυσικά όχι όταν σπουδαζά νομίζω οι φιλοδοξίες μου ήταν πολύ λίγο επαγγελματικές
περισσότερο σκεφτόμουν την προσωπική μου ζωή και το πως θα ήθερ πος φαντάζουμε των αντρέα
σαν οικογένειάρχην και λιγότερος σαν επαγγελματία στην μπορείαν ι ζωή αλλάζει αυτά που περιμένεις δεν
είναι απαραίτητα αυτά που έρχονται ήρθαν και με βρήαν κάποιες ευκαιρίές τις οποίες εκμεταλεύτηκα νομίζωκαι
ημε εδώ που είμε τώρα πως βρεθηκάτεστοτημόνι τη σταείχα αποφασίσει να επιστρέψω στην κύπρον το
δοι